bonjour jean marie le guen jours on va
parler un peu si vous voulez bien de la
primaire à gauche puisqu'elle va avoir
lieu
on va regarder ce que vous en disiez il
ya quelques il ya quelques semaines vous
disiez ceux qui sont prononcés le plus
fortement pour une primaire à gauche
sont ceux qui veulent écarter la
candidature de françois hollande ont
pourtant aujourd'hui et françois
hollande il s'est rallié à l'idée d'une
d'une primaire est ce que vous regrettez
justement que ce scrutin ait lieu que
j'ai un avis partagé mais il faudrait
peut-être un peu plus dedans je ne sais
pas si on en a mais c'est un petit peu
bon écoutez je pense que c'est une idée
qui est très reçus par nos compatriotes
que nous avons mis en oeuvre et qui a le
mérite de dépasser des appareils pour
dire des choses à gauche et à droite qui
sont assez sclérose et donc de ce point
de vue c'est un élément positif et
démocratique là où j'ai un peu plus de
doute c'est que cette primaire organise
à gauche à droite un débat où les gens
de gauche par là aux gens de gauche et
les gens de droite aux gens de droite
or je crois que la démocratie c'est pas
d'essayer de se comparer à l'intérieur
d'une part de marché si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi
qui est assez limité mais c'est
d'essayer d'attirer des gens qui ne se
sentent ni de gauche ni de droite voire
même de débattre aussi avec des gens de
droite et donc l'inde
l'inconvénient des primaires c'est de
rester chacun sur une zone une fan zone
en quelque sorte puisque c'est l'époque
et donc qu'on parle à sa fan zone on
parle pas à l'ensemble des français je
suis c'est ce qui me gêne un peu dans
cette affaire fait selon vous que
françois hollande justement accepté
finalement de cet exercice font parce
que j ai eu une polémique qui a été
menée sur le sujet bon là il faut et
deuxièmement c'est carrément n'ont cessé
bon moi j'étais assez réticent
s'agissant du président de la république
je trouve ça nous encore une fois c'est
je veux dire nous sommes au contraire
dans une
attitude d'ouverture alors je ne fallait
pas de confusion croire que la gauche
est un camp unanime dans lequel on il
s'agirait de distinguer entre les uns et
les autres juste sur leur physique ou
leur talent oratoire n'est pas sérieux
il faut pour qu'une primaires aient du
sens il faut qu'elle ait lieu sur la
base d'un territoire politique
bon nous sommes la gauche réformiste
nous sommes la gauche républicaine nous
ne sommes pas à la gauche radicaliser
nous sommes pas l'extrême gauche entend
donc mélanger notre primaire à l'extrême
gauche
ça ne s'est pas fait évidemment
mélenchon n'a jamais voulu le parti
communiste non plus un double non c'est
pas l'extrême gauche non non pas du tout
c'est une gauche contestataire et et
puis qui hésite un petit peu les
différents sentiers qu'il pourrait sur
lesquelles il pourrait s'aventurer
c'est toujours pas très claires de ce
point du manuel valls elle parle de deux
gauches irréconciliables est-ce que vous
souscrivez à cette analyse est ce que
justement arnaud montebourg il fait
partie de l'autre gauche jeu quand il
parle de gauches irréconciliables il
considère que dans la gauche radicaliser
il y a aujourd'hui des gens qui sont
parfois violent mais même qui ont tout
simplement un assentiment à la violence
qui n'est pas acceptable ou qui ont un
assentiment au communautarisme qui n'est
pas acceptable ou qui ont un assentiment
à une exacerbation des aides sociales
qui est dangereuse voilà et ce clivage
là il passe pas mon avis entre la gauche
et la gauche contestataire il passe à
l'intérieur de la gauche contestataire
il y à une gauche républicaine qui est
la gauche réformiste est sans doute une
gauche plus plus rugueuse plus robuste
mais qui est aussi une gauche
républicaine chez les communistes il ya
une tradition de la gauche républicaine
et puis il ya une tradition de de vue
j'allais dire de d'acceptation de
tolérance à la violence ou à la haine
sociale qui me pose problème à sion du
cobra même communauté la question
justement du communisme dans votre
récent ouvrage la gauche qui vient vous
parlez des islamo gauchiste en désignant
certaines figures de la gauche radicale
dont clémentine autain c'est une
question centrale selon vous la question
de l'identité
vous dites que justement il faut avoir
le courage de dire les choses pour
combattre le
front national mais l'islamo gauchisme
c'est aussi un terme qui est employé au
front national est ce que certains
rayons de france de laïcité même et de
république sans un point d'étape qui
fait polémique et non ses jeux les
employés parce que j'estime qui
correspond au fait qu'il y à une
fraction de la gauche radicaliser qui
pour des raisons semble-t-il mal placé
considère par définition que l'on doit
être tolérant et compréhensif avec un
certain nombre de gens qui se pare des
vertus de la victimisation
je pense que c'est une erreur il faut
évidemment être compréhensif et on quand
je parle islamo-gauchiste je parle pas
de l'islam je ne peux pas je parle de
cette fraction radicaliser
fondamentaliste de l'islam avec lesquels
quand on est républicain laïque de
gauche avec un certain nombre de valeurs
de gauche
on ne peut pas avoir d'accord voilà sur
françois hollande
il ya en tout cas est la question la
plus vendue de la femme par exemple
fusée mois ci la gauche met de côté le
statut de la femme d'un côté l'égalité
homme femme le fait qu' il y ait des
pressions qui s'exercent sur les
comportements des individus à
l'intérieur d'un certain nombre de
milieux d'un certain nombre de quartiers
c'est totalement contraire mais je suis
révulsé du point de vue de mes valeurs
de gauche
ça concerne le parti socialiste ça il
peut y avoir il compris au sein du parti
socialiste des gens qui ne mesurent pas
aujourd'hui les dégâts et qui par
opportunisme peuvent ça existe dans tous
les partis d'ailleurs vite si je ne vise
personne je dis simplement vide et qui
vire au nas il peut y avoir et on sait
bien qu'il ya eu ici dans toutes les
formations politiques compris
républicaine des tentations de suivre la
problématique communautariste pour des
raisons électorales ça existe voilà donc
j'appelle les consciences parce que je
sais que les gens qui parfois pratique
le communautarisme ou ont une tolérance
vis-à-vis du communautarisme
ils le font par électoraliste pas et non
pas par conviction et donc je les
appelle à suivre leurs convictions est
ce que je suis prêt s'il
ça va être la mission est ce que ça est
la mission de manuel valls après 2010
est de justement faire évoluer le
logiciel du ps sur ces questions et
logiciel du ps il évolue d'ores et déjà
la clarification elle se fait alors moi
je suis celui qui l'assument peut-être
plus clairement que d'autres mais enfin
on voit bien que la gauche est en train
de bouger elle a bougé il ya maintenant
une dizaine d'années sur les questions
de sécurité
elle a bougé il ya déjà un certain
nombre d'années sur la question de la
laïcité et je suis plus précis
s'agissant du communautarisme et elle a
bougé sur les questions économiques et
sociales
elle a bougé évidemment la petite
question sur la nation sur la république
elle bouge cette gauche elle devient
social réformiste allons un peu de
françois hollande et de son interview
dans les échos il a multiplié les
annonces sur les baisses d'impôt ou la
prime à l'embauché cice c'est quoi c'est
l'ébauché d'un programme présidentiel la
droite elle dénonce déjà des mesures
électoralistes
oui mais encore une fois il est quand
ils les pros mais être multipliée par
cinq
ce sont des mesures de bon sens et quand
d'une façon très pragmatique le
président la république annonce des
choses concrètes qui vont se mettre en
place dès les mois qui viennent lassé
des cadeaux alex croire jacques soucy
sur un radeau mina qui se projette sur
l'après 2010 est aussi clairement oui
bien sûr donc ça veut ça veut dire
quelque chose ça veut dire que il est
nul dans la chanson à la jambe de bois
évidemment mais d'ailleurs
sommes là bien sûr qu'ils se placent
dans ses filets en panne pour ça il fait
pas campagne
il gère et il dit je m'engage une
politique qui a vocation à aller au delà
de 2010 merci merci jean marie le guen
sait sciemment le mot de la fin